we will look very very closely at what
statements come out from this meeting
um the the simple truth is this war is
unprovoked it was illegal it was
unjustified uh we have made it
absolutely clear that we're helping the
ukrainians defend themselves but also as
I said in New York at the United Nations
at the tail end of last week we are also
defending the UN Charter international
law territorial Integrity all these
things okay um
19.
for brexit
I already have it a deal then why did we
have to do another deal
so I think you the deal that was done
the oven ready deal yeah that was the
withdrawal agreement that was to enable
us to actually leave the European Union
which we did in
um uh in January of 2020.
um so what we have been doing what we've
been negotiating over the last few
months and what was resolved yesterday
between the Prime Minister and Ursula of
underline was the uh the details about
ensuring that Northern Ireland remains a
meaningful full part of the United
Kingdom whilst also of course having
privileged access to the European single
Market making sure that the institutions
of the Good Friday agreement
particularly the Stormont executive are
back up and running
and resolving these last residual issues
in terms of that relationship when you
say last residual
[Music]
under
the alcohol now it's been fixed Parcels
unnecessary bureaucracy fixed online
shopping extra barriers now fixed and
planted potatoes banned now fixed pets
costly certificates band no fix the list
goes on and on and on lots of people
would have thought that had already been
sorted out it quite clearly had not the
leader the opposition is now saying that
this is a compromise
what you're offering why is he wrong
I mean the leader of the opposition
wouldn't understand I think how
negotiations work it seems because well
I mean if it's me well if you discover
on the phone somebody well if he
describes it as a compromise uh I think
uh What uh what I've heard is uh
Business Leaders Community leaders
representatives of uh retail Community
um the uh bespokesperson from the guide
dogs Association a whole load of other
people really welcome what we've
achieved because what we've achieved is
something that a lot of people said we
could never achieve which is a
negotiated change to
um the the treaties that underpin the
the the the the cross IRC trade and also
the relationship with Northern Ireland
and Ireland we've got now a very a
really really good result it means that
Northern Ireland is in the same uh tax
environments as the rest of the UK it
means the deal signed off it's not been
signed off yeah well it means that it
means that
products from within the UK can flow as
freely from Birmingham to Belfast it's
not been signed off yet but the this is
this is a really really good this is a
really really good uh uh agreement which
as I say protects Northlands part of the
of the UK also gives them that
privileged access to the single market
and and I think really really
importantly gives the elected
representatives of the people of
Northern Ireland a genuine say in the
rules and regulations you need the dup
on side what's the boss going to say
when it goes to Northern Ireland this
morning well I think what he's going to
do he's going to talk through the
practicalities of what's been agreed we
took the we we listen very very
carefully to the people the businesses
and the elected representatives in
Northern Ireland particularly the
unionist community and their
representatives who who really felt that
the protocol was was severing that that
that incredibly important link between
Northern Ireland and the rest of the
United States that was because you're
old boss your big body said that there
wouldn't be a border down the Irish sea
and it might be a softer one now but
it's still there
so so when it comes to the movement of
goods within the UK
there will be no greater regulatory
burden than moving things from
Birmingham to Braintree still a border
no there isn't okay okay so why do we
need to have a green and and red um
because the red lane is for stuff that
ultimately will be crossing a border
into the European Union into Ireland to
the European Union but within the UK
there is no border the regulatory
environment is exactly the same as if
it's moving anywhere else within the UK
products that weren't available in North
Island will be available meat products
sausages for example seed potatoes from
Scotland
yes so so so this this means that the
the uh um the nursery the the garden
center that I visited Northern Ireland
who could not get roses who could not
get Oak saplings who couldn't see
because of your old boss you could not
get sea potatoes they can now get all of
these things just as easily as if
they're in my constituency so the dup
don't agree with you then they don't
understand negotiations either like Pier
Starman they are going to quite
understandably want to look at the
detail of this of course of course they
will want to look at the detail of this
but I really hope that once they look at
the detail of this they will they will
see that we have taken back
well I'm not gonna I'm not gonna uh I'm
going to I'm going to give and I know
them respect them very very uh March and
they know
um I I know all the uh the MPS of the
dup and I've had a chance to meet their
leadership uh in Northern Ireland I
think they will know that I've been very
very focused on the concerns that they
have expressed on behalf of their
communities
that they will have real Authority when
it comes to the Stormont break they will
have a genuine save the power to
discover a deal well what I really
really hope is they'll look at this and
they will understand they still have the
power to discover a deal well look
ultimately this is about making sure
that the people of Northern Ireland are
served properly that means getting the
storm do they still have the power to
Scupper a deal well if if if if if they
don't re-enter
um uh the power sharing executive that
will be hugely disappointing I think
that'll be that'll be that won't be good
news for the people in Northern Ireland
but I think this deal do they still have
the power to Scupper a deal ultimately
yes we want Stormont up and running that
is something and I'm not I'm I I what I
want to do and I know your question what
I want to do what I want to do is I want
to give the dup I want to give the
representatives the unionist community
the chance to read this I want I want
them I want them to how many times do I
have to ask you because I tell you
because I know what you want to do you
want to I want you to tell me the answer
well you and it's a yes or no you're not
trapping you I'm asking you is do they
still have the power to Scupper a deal
the dup or are they not as powerful as
they used to be well you see and that's
why I'm that's why I'm not going to be
drawn into this because because this is
not this is no because actually the real
giveaway was the subsequent question
about are they not as powerful as they
used to be the dup are passionate
representatives of their communities in
Northern Ireland they've raised
a number they raised a number of
concerns about the implementation of the
protocol we listen very very carefully
and we have systematically gone through
to resolve the issues to make sure that
the tax and Regulatory environments
I've just read them all out for people
that's my question about the dup and
whether they're still powerful enough so
you'll recognize that the commission has
moved a very very long way from the
start absolutely that they've agreed
things that we were told with great
confidence would never be agreed
um
the king if I may just before I let you
go I know that you're a little bit cross
about talking about the king who asked
for the king to speak to host uh Mrs
Wonderland was it Downing Street or was
it Buckingham Palace well obviously we
arranged for uh Ursula vondeline to come
to the UK to conduct the final part of
the negotiation we of course uh inform
the palace and ultimately with the
visiting of any senior International
and he said yeah okay whether it be
whether it be president zielinski or
present uh Wonderland from the EU so but
ultimately leave decisions about the the
king's diary are rightly for the uh for
the palace eight minutes flies bus I
doesn't know it's good to talk to you as
always thanks